[Musique]
rudy
bonsoir à tous vous savez moi je veux
sauver le monde mais à chaque fois que
je dis aux gens que je veux sauver le
monde
ils me regardent d'un air interrogateur
voilà c'est exactement ce que vous
faites présentement
et pourtant c'est ce que je fais à
travers la recherche pas comme ces
chercheurs qui cherchent et qui ne
trouve pas mais comme ces chercheurs qui
cherchent et qui trouvent sur moi même
trouver une solution qui pourra qui
pourrait nous aider à lutter contre ce
fléau
ce fléau que nous connaissons tous ce
fléau que nous subissons de jour en jour
ce fléau qui sèment la terreur et la
désolation dans nos vies ce fléau viewty
est en train de nous décimer à petit feu
vous l'aurez sans doute deviné ce fléau
c'est le changement climatique car
jamais dans l'histoire de l'humanité
nous avons auteurs étaient autant
frapper comme ces derniers années
les inondations à répétition d'ailleurs
et vous le savez bien les nombreuses
richesses les épidémies rappelez-vous la
tête les mollahs et toutes ces maladies
pour ces maux qui minent notre planète
aujourd'hui ne sont rien d'autre que les
conséquences du changement climatique
dont l'une des principales causes est la
pollution de l'environnement
entendez par la pollution de l'eau
pollution de l'air pollution du son
avec moi ce soir on parlera de la
pollution de l'air et ne voyez pas que
s'imposer par logo tout le voiture nos
usines les combustibles fossiles
excitant parce que les ruminants
dans le monde animal polluent et
contribuer énormément au réchauffement
climatique
au fait est ce que vous aimez la viande
du mouton
j'aimais bien la viande du mouton mois
ci j'adore pour la tendresse de sa chair
son goût et son parfum si spécial c'est
d'ailleurs pourquoi j'aime ce jour si
particulier de l'année la tabaski ou le
mouton est à l'honneur dans nos
assiettes moutons sous tes tongs grillé
moutons 'alayhi wa ou qu'elle est ici
mais savez vous que le bouton rouge est
inoffensif et tous dans nos assiettes
est une véritable bombe à retardement
pour notre planète
et oui malheureusement nos moutons pour
lui et de la pire des façons je ne
comprenais pas je vous explique
il existe dans la panse de mouton une
multitude de petits éléments qui aiment
le foot on a bien digéré ce sont les
propos et les champignons et puis les
bactéries mais parmi ces bactéries
il n'ya ces bactéries qui n'ont rien à
voir avec la digestion du mouton en
réalité ce sont les ennemis du peuple
c'est pourquoi je les ai sûrement mais
la petite pépite par ce sont ces petites
bêtes qui vont faire monter les aliments
de la digestion du mouton afin de former
des cadres qui seront par la suite
libéré dans l'atmosphère
lorsque le bouton vote
j'ai bien envie de vous poser une
question qui vous a déjà vu ou entendu
un bouton vous madame
savez vous que nos moutons roth et c'est
pas que le mouton
il n'y a pas chez vous le but est tous
les ruminants du monde entier je vous
pose cette question parce que la
dernière fois que j'ai dit à mon angle
qui est même un éleveur que ces
ruminants roth mais il était non
seulement étonné choqué et scandalisé à
la fois parce que ces deux monnaies mais
comment des ruminants pour re-router et
je sais qu'aujourd'hui il y a encore des
gens au moment qu'ils ignorent que non
ruminants vote mais je vous dis ses
robes sont dangereux
c'est des gaz à effet de serre à cet
effet le dioxyde de carbone communément
appelée d'un symbolique est le gaz à
effet c'est le plus connu comme étant le
grand responsable des changements
climatiques les ans mais il y en a un
autre très dangereux et peut-être même
le plus redoutable encore le bétail qui
est l'un des d'azur au débat leur auto
étrange mérienne pas à nos moutons
europe du méthane dans l'atmosphère
cette pomme et visite va s'ajouter aux
états nuisible que nous avons dans
l'environnement pour détruit petit à
petit cette couche deux autres qui nous
protège des rayons solaires les plus
nocifs vous me direz c'est tellement que
le montant n'est pas le plus gros
pollueurs et que son méthane émis dans
l'atmosphère n'est pas un véritable
danger face aux quantités de doses
produites par des tombes et vous tu as
eu
dépend du mode de production plus un
animal et productifs plus il aimait neda
et venez pas sans ignorer sa avec
l'explosion démographique
la demande vient en laye a fortement
augmenté ce qui sous un pin
intensification de l'élevage utilisation
de moutons productif et par conséquent
votre émission de gaz
comment empêcher nos moutons de polluer
l'environnement
autrement dit des maîtres ce méthane
dans l'atmosphère dans tout l'état il
est quasiment impossible d'empêcher le
mouton dorothée c'est un phénomène
naturel
c'est un peu comme vous et moi quand on
voit deux trois ou quatre bouteilles
d'une boisson gazeuse au bout de 15
minutes
mais quoi de plus normal alors si on ne
peut pas empêcher le moteur de noter que
faire elle a ajouté que ces états sont
très dangereux et pour vous montrer la
dangerosité de ce gaz je vous invite à
une expérience une expérience que vous
avez sans doute déjà vécu le palus voir
cette maladie qui ne causait pas un si
petit moustique l'anophèle et je vous
dis là nos fins de comparable au méthane
du mouton quand elle vous piquent
rien de grave vous grattez et peut vous
vaquez à vos occupations d'aller au
bureau d'al au marché vous venez à tête
mix vous rigolez vous amuser rien de
grave
trois semaines après j'avais mal à la
tête
vous êtes fatigués si vous ne réagissez
pas la balle
évolué j'avais la fiv vous grelotter
j'avais mal aux reins vous avez mal
partout et c'est exactement ce que nous
vivons aujourd'hui
les inondations les épidémies la
poussière
la forte chaleur si vous ne réalisez
toujours pas est à toi cette année mais
parce que la maladie est pas beau
globules rouges
et puis un beau matin vous effectuez ce
malheureux voyage vers l'horizon mais
voilà pourquoi j'ai décidé de me battre
je dis pas de batna boutons mais
d'éliminer le fabricant du banc
autrement dit ces petites bêtes
directement dans la panse de mouton
mais comment faire alors j'ai imaginé
deux solutions première solution scotché
la bouche des moutons une solution
qu'elle sans doute inefficace
sinon l'est qui devait passer par la
bouche de s'échapper ailleurs et il
pourrait encore plus dangereux
ça ne marche pas alors la deuxième
solution éliminer ces fabricants du
monde autrement dit ces petites bêtes
dans la panse de mouton en utilisant des
produits pharmaceutiques
là aussi ça marche pas fan non seulement
sécher ils ont de la portée des élèves 1
et puis vous imaginez toute la
gymnastique qui aurait autour de 1000
têtes
que faire si ce n'est que de se confier
à dame nature ne dit on pas quelle est
notre maître nourricier depuis la nuit
des temps l'homme a toujours puisé dans
la nature pour se louer ce soit y est
ils se vêtir aujourd'hui encore dame
nature de cesse de nous émerveiller à
travers ses bienfaits et n
le coin
mais on ne la cherchez pas il suffit de
tendre la main pour l'appui pour toutes
ces raisons je me suis tourné vers elle
je me suis tous les vins c'est lui qui
nous auraient un doute que les plantes y
les plantes médicinales puisqu'elles
sont efficaces ou plusieurs maladies
disponible et accessible à tous une
plante que j'ai particulièrement tester
ces attaques aériennes connu sous le nom
de la gauche italienne
et bien c'est une plante qui est
beaucoup utilisé en médecine
traditionnelle vous soigner les
infections de la bouche du labourage la
diarrhée et même la dysenterie
elle est aussi très riche année les
motifs disons autrement riche en petites
machines chimiques qui font de la plante
un médicament dont un alicament est un
argument n'est rien d'autre qu'un
aliment médicament ajouté donc à
l'alimentation du mouton
ces machines chimiques que sont les
éléments hâtives on agit sur la
population de ces petites bêtes pour non
seulement réduit le membre le émissions
de méthane dans la panse et
l'élaboration de ce gaz dans
l'atmosphère
voyez vous même le pouvoir de nos
plantes médicinales mesdames et
messieurs nous nous avons évité ce
travail est un cri d'alerté pour que
nous prenions conscience que le méthane
et mais pas le mouton est réel c'est une
pomme une véritable pomme arrêt
tellement pour notre planète
malheureusement elle arrive lentement
mais sûrement et 7 aujourd'hui et
maintenant que nous devons agir sinon
dans 50 ou 100 ans ce serait tout à ses
pas
j'ai commencé avec le mouton et vous je
vous remercie
[Musique]